[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض فيها اهم المواضيع وفي
العناوين
طيران
من هيئه الامم المتحده للمراه
انفجارتنا عنيفه تهز العاصمه كيه ودفاعات
الجويه اوكرانيه تسقط عشره سيارات ايرانيه
وزير الدفاع الامريكي يحذر قاده افريقيا
من الدوري الذي ستلعبه الصين وروسيا في
القاره السمراء
نجم التانجو الارجنتيني
ميسيكون الاخير في مسيرته الكرويه
بالمونديال
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من الاحتجاجاته
في ايران حيث تواصل وسلطه الايرانيه
بالسجن الى 10 سنوات
وعلى 80 شخصا من سجن من سنتين الى خمس
سنوات وعلى 160 شخصا لمده
الايراني
تحدي القوات
الامريكيه الذي تقام فيه مراسم تامين
الشعب مجيد رضاها رحمه ورده
[موسيقى]
غرب ايران اجراءات امنيه مشدده بعد ما
تجمع الاهالي امام مبنى قائم مقام جوان
جود وطالبوا باطلاق سراح رجل الدين سيف
الله حسين كما استمر تجمعات واضرابات
الطلاب في مختلف الجامعات الايرانيه
احتجاجا على عمليات الاعدام على الرغم من
مصادره بطاقه الشخصيه والهواتف المحموله
لعدد من الطلبه
اعربت النقابه الدوليه للاعبي كره القدم
المحترفين في فيبرو عن صدمتها لمواجهه
لاعب كره القدم الايراني امير ناصر ازادان
البالغ من عمر سته وعشرين عاما خطر صدور
حكم بالاعدام بحقه لاسباب متصله بتظاهرات
التي تشهدها ايران منذ ثلاثه اشهر واعلنت
النقابه في حسابه على تويتر
بان لاعب كره القدم المحترف امير ناصر
الزدان يواجه خطا الاعدام بعد ما شارك في
حمله للدفاع عنه حقوق النساء والحريات
الاساسيه في بلاده
من قبل النظام الايراني المحتجي الى ردود
الفعل الدوليه حيث كشف وزير خارج
البريطاني جيمس كليفرلي انا بلاده قد تفرض
المزيد من العقوبات على النظام الايراني
وذلك على خلفيه تهديدات تعرض لها صحفي دون
مزدوج الجنسيه في بريطانيا واكدت ليفر
لانه من غير المجد الكشف عن العقوبات
مسبقا مشددا في الوقت ذاته على ان بلاده
وعزيمه على ضمان عدم ترهيب اي مواطن
بريطاني من قبل النظام الايراني خصوصا
الصحفيون الذين يصلون الضوء على ما يجري
في ايران وان بريطانيا ستقف امام اي
تدخلات خارجيه
المشاهدين ولايات المتحده من خلال جلسه
المجلس الاقتصادي والاجتماعيه التابعي
المتحده لاستبعاد ايران من هيئه المراه
المعانيه بالمساواه بين المسلمين وتمكين
المراه وكل ما تحتاجه واشنطن عند التصويت
على مشروع قرارها لطلبه من عضويه هيئه وضع
المراه هو الاغلبيه البسيطه داخل المجلس
المكون من اربعه 54
حيث ان كثيرا من الاعضاء غير مرتاحين لهذا
الطرد غير المسبوق لدوله عضو في هيئه وضع
المراه بالاضافه الى الامم المتحده التي
التزمت الصمت حول التحرك الامريكي الاخير
لكن يرى المراقبون بان الولايات المتحده
لديها عدد كاف من الاصوات لتحقيق ما تريد
مشاهدينا من لندن ينضم الينا الباحث في
شان الايراني وجدان عبد الرحمن اهلا بك
سيد وجدان معنا في هذه النشره كما تابعنا
الضغوط على المحتاجين تتوالى تاره
بالاعدامات واخرى بالسجن لمدد طويله هل
تنجحوا هذه الاستراتيجيه من النظام في كسر
عزيمه المحتاجين
صباح الخير
لكل الكرام لو كان هذا الامر يكثر عزم
المحتاجين الا ما انتفضوا الان بعد
احتجاجات 2019 التي راحها ضحيهتها اكثر من
قتيل وايضا الكثير منهم توفيو تحت التعذيب
في السجون الايرانيه هذه الاراده لم تنكسر
بالعكس اراده النظام هي التي انكسرت دوليا
وداخليا وسقطت هيبته في الداخل الايراني
وايضا حتى لدى حلفائه هذه جرائم التي يقوم
بها النظام الايراني ان كان يظن بانه من
خلال الاعدامات او من خلال الاستخدام
الرصاص الحي همم لتفريغ المحتاجين بانه
انتصر انه مقطعين همم تماما والخاسر هو
النظام خلال هذه الفتره شاهدنا انه النظام
تعرض خسائر كباريات خسائر كبيره هذه
الخسائر كانت ماديه من خلال القطع
الانترنت والعقوبات التي تعرضت على النظام
الايراني وايضا الاقتصاد الذي همم شله همم
الاضراب اضافه الى الخسائر البشريه اليوم
حتى يعني
هذه الحمله ايضا تستهدف الصحفيين نحن
نتحدث عن اعتقال اكثر من 70 صحفيه منذ
بدايه هذه الاحتجاجات منذ ثلاثه اشهر وهو
عدد ليس بالهج لماذا استهداف هذه الفئه
تحديدا
لان هذه الفئه تعكس ما يعمله
المحتجون في الداخل قطع الانترنت بالاساس
لكي صوت الاحتجاجات وصوت الاضرابات العامه
صوت الحق ان لا يخرج الى خارج البلاد
واللا تنعكس هذه الاخبار وهؤلاء الصحفيون
ايضا هم من يقومون
بارسال وايضا انعكاس الصوت المظلوميه التي
تحدث في داخل الايراني لذلك يتم
اعتقالهم وايضا حتى اغتيالهم لذلك النظام
يريد اسكات اي صوت وهؤلاء هم صوت همم
الشارع همم يصل الى المجتمع الدول ولذلك
يتم اعتقالهم بهذه الطريقه اي من يكون
بعمل اعلامي او صحفي يعكس صوت الشارع بكل
تاكيد سيتم اعتقال وايضا حتى بعض همم
الاطباء وايضا حتى الرياضيين
لم يقوموا باي عمل همم اجرامي اتجاه
النظام الايراني وانما كل ما قام به هو
انعكاس الصوت
الشارع لذلك تم قمعهم بهذه الطريقه التي
نشدها يتم الحكم اعدام على اطباء ورياضيين
وايضا فنانين للاسف الشديد
والمجتمع الدولي حتى الان
ما يتعلق بالاعدام التجديد الدولي ياخذوا
همم تصاعديا فيما يتعلق بالاعدام هل تعتقد
ان المجتمع الدولي بامكانه وقف هذه
السياسه سياسه اعداماتها انه عاجز تماما
امام النظام الايراني في تقديرك باختصار
لو سمحت جديد
للاسف لم يقوم بواجبه اتجاه ما يحدث في
الداخل همم الايراني والقرارات والعقبات
التي يتخذها لم تمنع النظام الايراني لانه
تعود على موضوع همم
العقوبات لذلك انه ما يهمه البقاء في
السلطه ولذلك حتقد انه سيمارس الضغوط كبير
على المحتاجين وسيقوم باعدامات كبيره في
الداخل الايراني من لندن كتب معنا الباحث
في شان الايراني وجدان عبد الرحمن شكرا لك
سيد وجدان على هذه المشاركه
دعم مبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا عبد الله
بعتيلي القاده الليبيين الى وضع حد
للمراحل الانتقاليه والتوجه نحو التحضير
للانتخابات من اجل جعل عام 2023 عام سلام
واستقرار في ليبيا وحتى باتيل في بيان
نشرتها البعثه الاميه جميع الاطراف
شعبهم مشيرا الى ان شباب ليبيا لم يعد
بحاجه الى فنادق الكلاشنكوف وانما لتوفيق
للمدارس والتقنيه الحديثه وفرص الاقتصاديه
الحقيقيه
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
صامت والانتخابيه لتونسي الخارج في السباق
البرلمان
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في تونس بينما
توشك لحمله الانتخابيه في الداخل على
النهايه ينطلق الصمت الانتخابي اليوم في
الخارج باعتبار ان عمليه الاقتراع في دواء
للخارج تتواصلوا على مدى ثلاثه ايام وذلك
وفق الخطط التي اقرتها هيئه العليا
المستقله للانتخابات
مع بدايه العد التنازلي لاجراء الاستحقاق
التشريعي الاول بعد الاجراءات الاستثنائيه
في تونس غابت كل المظاهر الانتخابيه او
تكاد و رغم ان الحمله الانتخابيه توشيكو
على النهايه في الداخل فانها لم تشهد
التنافس المعهوده في الانتخابات السابقه
اما المواطنون فقد اختلفت ارائهم بين
مساند للمصار الانتخابيه ورافض له
البلاد
جماعتها وخلتنا نحن في السفر خلت البلاد
التنظيميه واللوجستيه لاجراء الانتخابات
في الداخل والخارج وكانت اخر خطواتها
تامين وصول المواد الانتخابيه الى مختلفه
يؤ المتابعون انها ستشكل حجر الاساس في
طبيعه المشهد السياسيه التونسي مستقبلنا
قد تتغير نسبيا في الساعات القادمه
باعتبار الحماس التي قد تطفو للسطح جرار
عمل بعض المترشحين او هيئه الانتخابات
للتدارك لكن همم يبقى الرهان على هذا
الاستحقاق لتحقيق همم المحطه الاخيره في
مشروع رئيس
الانتخابات على ان تتم عمليه التصويت على
مدى ثلاثه ايام في الخارج على ان يكون يوم
التصويت في الداخل في السابع عشر من شهر
ديسمبر كانون الاول
مع دخوله في مرحله الانتخابيه في الخارج
والحصار الانتخابات التشريعيه في ثلاث
دوائر فقط من اصل الى 10 تتواصلوا الحمله
الانتخابيه في الداخل باهته وقد غابت عنها
جل ومظاهر تنافس في اول انتخابات تشريعيه
بعد اقرار الاجراءات الاستثنائيه في
البلاد وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس
كشف المتحدث هو باسمي وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه جنرال الباترايدر في مؤتمر صحفي
انا الولايات المتحده استانفذ بالكامل عمل
الدوريات المشتركه مع قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في شمال سوريا وذلك بعد
تعليقها الشهر الماضي بسبب الضربات الجويه
التركيه في المنطقه
تداول ناشطون عبر المنصات التواصل
الاجتماعي
يظهر فيها اصوات بل تظهر فيها اصوات دوليه
فيما اعلن رئيس بلديه
الدفاع الجوي الاوكرانيه اسقطت 10 طائرات
مسيره من طراز الشاهد المصنوعه في ايران
في ساعه مبكره من الصباح اليوم
منك يا مشاهدين ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
حذيفه عادل اهلا بك حذيفه وهل ما زال
التوتر في هذا الموقف العاصمه كيف ام ان
الاوضاع عاده طبيعتها
نعم تحياتي احمد يعني عدد الى 13 طائره
انتحاريه من طراز شاهد او كمكازي ااا 136
ااه استهدفت العاصمه كيف كان الاستهداف
لامناطق همم المنشات البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه كمافات
هو القائد العسكري للمنطقه وقال ان القوات
الدفاع الجوي استطاعت ان تسقط الطائرات
الثلاثه عشر جميعها ولكن طبعا هنالك طائره
عندما تمت اصابتها سقطت في احدى في احد
المباني السكنيه في منطقه شفشاونكو همم لم
يتضرر المبنى كثيرا ولم يكن هنالك اصابات
ايضا هنالك مبني اداريين في منطقه الشينكو
كذلك من المباني الاداريه في الحي ايضا
اتضرر بعض الشيء ولكن لا يوجد اصابات في
هذه المنطقه حتى الان لا يوجد صبات بشكل
عام في مقاطعه التي اطلقت نحوها هذه
الطائرات المسيره كذلك طبعا هنالك ضربه
همم استهدفت مناطق زباروجا او مدينه انت
زبراجه ايضا لا يوجد حتى هذه اللحظه اي
اصابات او جرح ناعم طيب حذيفه يعني هذه
الدفاعات الاخرانيه اسقطت 13 مسير ايرانيه
رغم ان البلاد ما زالت بانتظار منظومه
البتريوت الامريكيه بعد ايام التي ستصل
الى اوكرانيا بعد ايام الى اي مدى تعول
اصل هذا الاوكرانيه في قدرتها على تامين
الاجواء الاوكرانيت بعض وصول هذه المنظومه
الى البلاد
نعم هنالك التحويل الكبير خاصه على هذه
المنظومه مع ان بعض المنظمات وصلت فعليه
الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه ولكنها تستخدم
الان في المناطق القتاليه وطبعا هنالك عدد
من المنظمات وصلت وهنالك منظومات متوسطه
ايضا ااه يعني تم توزيعها ولكن طبعا
المنطقه او المساحه شاسعه التي يجب ان
تقوم القوات الجويه
بحمايتها لذلك ما زالت تنتظر المزيد من
المنظمات المتوسطه والمنظمات متقدمه
وباترول تحديدا يعول عليها كثيرا طبعا
الاستهدافات التي تتم لمناطق الطاقه في
ولايه واحده في جميع الولايات في جميع
انحاء اوكرانيا يتازم اكثر فاكثر همم
هنالك حتى في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف ال-
ال- الضفه اليسرى همم بتعملي كهرباء هنالك
عدد كبير من المدن والقرى والبلدات او في
المدن الاخرى وخاصه في الشرق الاكرانيا
وفي جنوب البلاد واجسام تعاني لذلك يعول
كثيره طبعا السلطات الاوكرانيه ترى انه لا
جدوا من اي عمليات صيانه او اي تغيير ما
لم يكن هنالك منظومه الدفاع منظومه الدفاع
الجوي لاغلاق السماء
حذيفه عادل تحياتي حذيفه
مشاهدينا قال نائب وزير الخارجيه روسيه
الشرقيه
حتى تتمكن من توزيع العمل وفقا لتقديرها
الخاص واضح ان اقتراح وضعي حد اقصى معين
للافراد سيمكن الرؤساء والامريكيين من
تحديد عد الاشخاص المطلوبين في الاقسام
المختلفه مضيفين انه حتى الان لم يتم
الحصول على رد معتبرا ان هذه القضيه واحده
من اهم القضايا التي نقشت خلال اجتماع في
اسطنبول الى الاسبوع الماضي على حد وصفيه
النظام الدفاع الصاروخيه الى اوكرانيا
مطالبه
[موسيقى]
تحديد رصيد بشكل جديد قد يطرق باب القاره
العجوز تقارير غربيه كشفت ان الدول
الاوروبيه قديمه
او معرفه معلومات امنيه عنها
اخفاقات عديده للقوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وعزله دوليه من كل حب لكن يبدو ان ادوات
الرئيس الروسي القديمه
او لمعرفه المدى الذي يمكن ان تصل له
الحرب في حال تطور الصراع ليشمل دول
الغربيه الدول الاوروبيه بدورها باتت تنتج
استراتيجيات المختلفه لمواجهه روسيا
فنلندا التي تمتلك اطول حدود مع روسيا
قررت منع دخول اي مواطن روسي يحمل تاشيره
سياحيه اما النرويج فقد قررت رفع ميزانيه
الدفاع ب 10% وتفكر في اعاده اي مواطن
روسي الى حدود بلاده في حين تعمل فرنسا
بطرق مختلفه لمواجهه السوسي الروسيه فهي
تلجا حين لطرد الجواسيس الى بلدهم وحينا
تعزلهم بصوره سريه
معطيات عده ربما تدفع الكرمل لاتباع النهج
نشر الجواسيس في اوروبا في ربما يرتكز بوت
على ما حدث في المانيا من محاوله انقلاب
وما اظهرته الدوله من هشاشه امنيه كارضيه
لمخططاته لمستقبليه بضرب اوروبا الى جانب
ما يدور في اروقه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي من
انقسام في المواقف التي تظهرها غير موحده
اضافه الى قضايا الفساد التي خرجت الى
العالم في البرلمان الاوروبي
تحدي سياسيا واستراتيجي وراء محاولات
التجسس للكرمله وبات التهديد الروسي يتخذ
اشكال متعدده عسكريا في اوكرانيا وامنيا
في اوروبا وفق اجهزه الاستخبارات الغربيه
وارد على ضرب اهداف المدنيه باوكرانيا
قامت بريطانيا بفرد عقوبات على شخصيات من
ايران وروسيا
[موسيقى]
سته الاف مدنيين لقوا حتفهم منذ بدايه
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا جراء الضربات
الصاروخيه والمدفعيه الروسيه حصيله ثقيله
دفعت بريطانيا مره جديده الى اصدار عقوبات
الشامله 12 قائدا بارز في الجيش الروسي
بينهم قائد لوحده توصل تحقيق الى ان
الوحده مسؤوله عن برمجه وتوجيه الصواريخ
الروسيه انتهاكات الخطيره للقانون
الانساني الدولي حسب البيان الذي اكد على
ضروره محاسبه المسؤولين عن هذه الهجمه
ايران مشموله بالعقوبه الجديده التي طالت
شركه مادو الايرانيه ومديرها يوسف ابو
طالبي والمسؤوله بمنظمه الجهاد للاكتفاء
الذاتي والبحوث التابعه للحرس الثوري عبد
الله محرابي ورئيس منظمه الصناعه الجويه
الايرانيه افشين خواجا فرد
الخارجيه البريطانيه اكدت ان الطائرات
المسيره ايرانيه الصنع لعب الدور الرئيسي
في الهجمات الروسيه على المدنيين
باوكرانيا
غير مقبوله على سبيل المثال توفير مسيله
عسكريه والتي يتم استخدامها في المدنيين
والبنيه التحتيه المدنيه من قبل روسيا في
اوكرانيا لقد فرضنا عقوبات على المطورطين
في ذلك
واشار البيان الى ان معلومات اصدرتها
الولايات المتحده مؤخرا تظهر ان ايران
اصبحت احد اكبر الداعمين العسكريين لروسيا
وان طهران ارسلت مئات الطائرات المسيره
الى روسيا في انتهاك الالتزاماتها
القانونيه الدوليه
القاده الافارقه خلال قمه واشنطن من ان
الصين وروسيا تلعبان دورا مزعزع لاستقرار
في القاره السمراء مع تنامي نفورهما
اسمح لي ان اعترف صراحه بالدوري الفعال
الذي تلعبه البلدان الافريقيه في مواجهه
بعض التحديات الاكثر اهميه للعالم الى
جانب هذه التحديات تواجه القاره تحديات
تمثلها روسيا والصين بالاضافه الى التحدي
الارهاب العابد للحدود فيما يتعلق بروسيا
والصين تقوم الاخيره بتوسيع بصمتها
اقتصاديه في القاره الافريقيه على اساس
اليوم وبطريقه غير شفافه اما روسيا فهي
تواصل بيع الاسلحه الرخيصه كما تقوم
بتوظيف المرتزقه في جميع انحاء القاره
وهذا يساهم في زعزعه الاستقرار
افادت وكاله البلومبيرج بان اداره الرئيس
الامريكي جوباين تخطط لوضع 35 شركه صينيه
لصناعه الرقائق الالكترونيه على قائمه
السوداء للتجاره حيث تمنع المجموعات
الامريكيه من بعد تكنولوجيا للشركات
المدرجه في القائمه ما لم يكن لديها ترخيص
تصدير يصعب الحصول عليه وتاتي هذه الخطوه
بعد شهرين من كشف الولايات المتحده عن
ضوابط صارمه على الصادرات جعلت من الصعب
على الصين الحصول على احداث اشباه
الموصلات وانتاجها
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل في
المونديال المنتخب اسود الاطلس يسعى لخطف
بطاقه التاهل لنهائي كاس العالم منذ فرسان
طيران تواصل معاقبه المحتجين بسجن المئات
وترجيحات بفض ايران هيئه الامم المتحده
للمراه
انفجارات عنيفه تهز العاصمه والدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه تسقط ثلاثه 10 مسيره
ايرانيه
وزير الدفاع الامريكي يحذر قاده افريقيا
من الدوري الذي تلعبه الصين وروسيا في
القاره السمراء
نجم التانجو الارجنتيني
ميسيكون الاخير في مسيرته الكرويه
بالمونديال
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اكد نجم
الارجنتين في كره القدم ليونيل ميسي ان
كاس العالم الحالي
انه سعيد باتمامه رحله كاس العالم والوصول
الى النهائي بعد فوز المنتخب على كرواتيا
بثلاثه اهداف نظيفه مؤكدا انها الطريقه
الانسب لانهاء مسيرته ميسي
يحاول الوصول الى اللقب في المباراه
النهائيه المباراه يوم الاحد والذي ستكون
اما مع المغرب او فرنسا
هو ايه المزيد من الاخبار الرياضيه في
التقرير التالي
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الى الموجز الرياض
وصل ليونيل ميسي قيادته لمنتخب بلاده نحو
الفوز وتجاوز برفقه نجوم التانجو منتخب
كرواتيا نحو نهايه كاس العالم بثلاثه
اهداف دونار الهدف الاول لمنتخب الارجنتين
جاء من ركله جزاء وضعها ميسي قويه في سقف
المرمى عند الدقيقه الرابعه والثلاثين ولم
يمنح الارجنتينيون كرواتيا فرصه للالتقاط
الانفاس ثم اضاف المهاجم جوليانا باريس
الهدف الثاني بعده بخمس دقائق انتهى عليه
ما الشوط الاول وفي النصف الثاني من
المباراه وبعد مجهود فردين عالي من ميسي
في المرمى هدفا ثالث عند الدقيقه التاسعه
والستين لتصل على الارجنتين الى المباراه
النهائيه بانتظار الفائز من مواجهات
المغرب وفرنس
كشف مدرب اسود الاطلس وليد الرجراجي قبل
لقاء نصف النهائي امام فرنسا بان منتخب
بلاده خاضا لمشوار الاصعب وسيقاتم لتحقيق
هدف
نود دخول التاريخ لا نريد الانتظار 40 سنه
حتى تكون هناك فرصه اخرى انها فرصتنا لوضع
فريق افريقيا عربي على قمه كاس العالم
ربما انا مجنون قليلا لكن البعض قال ان
افريقيا لديها خمس منتخبات بالمونديال
وعليها الاتفاق بذلك لا نحن هنا في نص
النهائي وسنحاول بلوغ النهائي نود تغيير
العقليه هذا ما بلغت به اللاعبين نامل ان
لا يحترمنا الخاص لانهم اذا لعبوا بافضل
مستوياتهم واحترمون فسيكون الامر صعبا
خذنا المشوار الاصعب والكل توقع ان نخرج
قلت في بدايه البطوله نحلم بالفوز بكاس
العالم وسنقاتل لتحقيق هدفنا
الكوسوفي
المنتخب
لا احب الحادثه عن الحماسه او الغدائيه
للمغرب افضليه جماهيريه كبيره وحذرته
اللاعبين وعلينا ان نستعد لكل شيء
البيت هو ما يجمع بين الافرقه ويضيف له
الفتها للعلاقات لكن في قطر ياتي ملعب
البيت ليفرق بين الاصدقاء مباراه فرنسا
والمغرب تحمل الكثير من التفاصيل لطرفه
تتصدر علاقه الصداقه المميزه بين مبابي
وحكيم المشهد قبل مواجهه فرنسا والمغرب
بالدوري نصف النهائي
باريس سان جيرمان كما كانت الصداقه بينهما
من خلال زياره تشجيع وتهنئه قام بها مبابي
لحكيم في معسكر الاسود بالدوحه قبل وبعد
مباراه اسبانيا بدور 16
لاعبان ضل يتبادلان رسائل التهنئه بعد كل
فوز لمنتخبنا الاسود والديوك في البطوله
مباراه فرنسا والمغرب تحمل خصوصيه كذلك
للثلاثي بوفال واوناحي واشرف داريه الذين
يلعبون ويتالون هذا الموسم مع انديه
فرنسيه بالاضافه
المولود في العاصمه باريس وقضى اغلب
مشواره الكروي بين سته انديه فرنسيه في
الطرف الاخر سيخذ ثنائي وعثمان ديمبلي
المباراه بمشاعره خاصه
تيك توك نصف المليون متابعه
حاله من الدعم لا محدود من كل اقطاب الارض
لصالح اسود الاطلس قبل المباراه التي
تفصلهم عن الكاس الغاليه امام المنتخب
الفرنسي
ثلاثون طائره و الاف مشجعين القادمين من
المغرب سيوجدون في الدوحه لمؤازره اسود
الاطلس في لقاء تاريخي بنصف نهائي كاس
العالم امام فرنسا
وتوافد الاف المشجعين على ملعب الجنوب منذ
ساعات الاولى من يوم الثلاثاء للحصول على
تذكره المباراه بعد ما تمكن اتحاد الكره
المغربي من توفير قرابه 10,000 تذكره
بالضبط
في المدن المغربيه ايضا ستعلق الشاشات حيث
تم تثبيت شاشات عملاقه في بعض القاعات على
غرار الشاشه الموجوده بملعب محمد الخامس
بالدار البيضاء وايضا بعيش بعد
باقبال كبير من طرف الجماهير بكل فئاتها
التاهل التاريخي لنصف النهائي مونديال قطر
منح شعورا بالتفاؤل والفقر في نفوس
المغاربه جعلهم ينسون لفتره وجيزه ظروفهم
الاقتصاديه الصعبه
في السنغال خرج العديد باعلام وقمصان اسود
الاطلس تشجيعا للانجاز المغربي
تخجل
الجاليه الفرنسيه في المغرب ستعيش مباراه
استثنائيه الالاف يوجدون في المغرب وهناك
من سيعيش شعورا خاصا لانتمائه للبلدين
[موسيقى]
كانت هذه ابرز واخبار المونديال شكرا لكم
على حسني المتحده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا ونعود الى الخبر العاجل
عن وسائل اعلام العراقيه التي افادت قبل
قليل بمقتل ضابط واصابه 14
العربيه منتدى الرشيد
نعم بالفعل الاب وكانت مزروعه عند احدى
الطرق الزراعيه
الذي يقع الى شمال
[موسيقى]
صلاح الدين وايضا الى الجهاز الغربيه
بمحافظه الانبار التاليه هذه منطقه همم
تحركا لعناصر داعش الذين
الان هذه الصوره للضابطه القتيل الذي هي
متداوله طبعا للضابط الذي قتل في هذا
الانفجار رفقه همم اصابه اربعه عسكريين
بفجر عبوه ناسبه في ناسفه في الطارميه
وذلك بحسب وسائل الاعلام عراقيه تفضل
منتظر
ته هذا الانفجار اربعه جنود
انتشر طبعا القوات امنيه وصلت الى مكان
هذا الهجوم
تحقيقاتها هناك قوه اخرى
[موسيقى]
دائما ما يهاجمون همم نقاط الجيش نقاط
التابعه للجيش همم
يهاجمون الدوري عن الجيش العراقي
العشائريه الموجوده في هذه هي المنطقه
الجديده حول هذا الانفجار شكرا لك طبعا
عبر الهاتف من بغداد مراسل العربيه منتظر
الرشيد
مشاهدينا بالعوده الى ملف الرياضيه ينضم
الينابي باريس مراسل العربيه حسين قنيبر
اهلا بك يا حسين وكيف يترقب الفرنسيين
مباراتهم اليوم مع المنتخب المغربي انقلنا
الاجواء رجاءا
صباح الخير احمد في الواقع انا هنا في
الضاحيه انيار الشيخ سان القريبه جدا من
باريس جئت الى هذه الضاحيه لان غالبيه من
دول المغرب العربي الجزائر تونس والمغرب
تحديدا تسكن في هذه الضاحيه هناك ترقب
لهذه المباراه الليله بين فرنسا والمغرب
معهد العبد النشره
85% من الفرنسيين احمد يعتقدون ان منتخبهم
سيفوز مساء اليوم في مواجهه المنتخب
المغربي
وطبعا كانت هناك توقعات ايضا في مذكره
داخليه للجهاز المركزي للاستخبارات
الفرنسيه توقعات بانه ايا تكون نتيجه
المباراه الليله بين المنتخبين مغربي
والفرنسي فان الحشود التي ستعقب انتهاء
المباراه ستكون حشودا ضخمه وستحصل
اضطرابات من قبلي اشخاص ليسوا بالضروره من
المحتفلين السلميه بفوز احد المنتخب وانما
من قبل الجهاد غالبا ما اعتادت على
استغلال مناسبات من هذا النوع ربما اطرح
سؤالا على احد همم مغاربه الفرنسيين من
اصول مغربيه هشام صباح الخير صباح الخير
ما رايك اولا بما توقعته همم معهد لعب
بالاستطلاع الذي نشر نتائجها من ان 85% من
الفرنسيين يعتقدون ان منتخبهم هو الذي
سيفوز مساء اليوم هذا استطلاع يمكن ان
نتفهم اذا يعني تموقعنا فرنسيين ولكن كم
غالبه ومن نظر الى يعني المسار يعني
البراق الذي يعني قام به المنتخب الى الان
والذي لم يكن وليد او محد الصدفه فهذا
يعني نحن المغاربه لا نؤمن به كثيرا نؤمن
بحدودنا بشكل واقعي وبالنظر كما يعني ذكرت
الى مسار يعني الرائع الذي يقدمه المغايبه
وهو في حذفه في حد ذاته انتصار يعني مهما
كانت نتيجه المباراه ولكن نبقى مؤمنين
بحدود المنتخب المغربي همم كممثل او يعني
همم
اكثر من ذلك كممثل لكل العالم العربي الذي
اشكره بالمناسبه على التضامن يعني
الرائع والتضامن الذي يعني
ابهر الفرنسيين والذي اعتقد ان هذا
الاستطلاع يعني يبرر نوعا ما همم هذه
الدهشه من التضامن الذي همم حظوه في كل
العالم العربي لم يكن يتوقع هذا الدفع هذا
التضامن الذي حضي به المنتخب المغربي نحن
اا كما قلت نبقى مؤمنين بحدودنا واكيد
المغربي سيقول كلمته ان شاء الله شكرا لك
هشام اشاره الى ان من بين المدن التي
ذكرتها المذكره الداخليه للجهاز المركزي
للاستخبارات الفرنسيه متوقعه الحصول
الاضطرابات فيها ستراسبور في الشرق وليل
وتركوا في الشمال الفرنسي وموبيليا
ومارسيليا في الجنوب اليوم في الجنوب
الشرقي هذه المدن قد تشهد اضطرابات كما
تقول المذكره الداخليه للجهاز المركزي
للاستخبارات الفرنسيه
للاضاءه ايضا في المدن الفرنسيه معك شكرا
لك من فارس كتب معنا مراسل العربيه
احمد تفضل حسين تفضل باختصار
عشره الاف عشره الاف شرطي فرنسي سيواكبون
الاحتفالات التي تعقب هذه المباراه بين
فرنسا والمغرب من بينهم 5000 ينتشرون في
باريس ومحيطها وفي باريس خصوصا عند جده
والجدات المجاوره لها احمد
باريس تحياتي
يتفاعل سكان الدار البيضاء المدينه
الحيويه الاكبر في المغرب مع مشاركه اسود
الاطلس في نهائيات كاس العالم ويعتبرون
انهم عادوا الاعتبار للمملكه
تتجه الانظار في اكبر مدن المغرب للمواجهه
الحاسمه مع فرنسا
صوت يحلو في كازابلانكا فوق زئير الاسود
الاطلس في المونديال بدانه زائر غير مخيف
وانما يثير الدهشه والبهجه في جميع فئات
المجتمع البيضاوي
سعيد العمراني
درست في المانيا المنتخب
فوتنا العرب عونك تعاونوا معنا شجعونا
بشرى الضو ناشطه المعروفه على وسائل
التواصل في الدار البيضاء وهي تواصل
حملتها لموازره المنتخب المغربي حتى
العوده بالكاس كما تقول
الاربعاء
انتم الثلاثه
ههه الطول تيم والاسود ويلتهم ومعاهم
المغاربه وان شاء الله الى
[موسيقى]
البير وفيما ينتشر ارتياح واسع وترتسم
ابتسامات على الوجوه في مدينه مازالت تعيش
على وكع التاهل التاريخي على حسابي
اسبانيا والبرتغال يامر سكان الدار
البيضاء ان تكتمل الفرحه بهزيمه فرنسا
خالد جنود العربيه دار البيضاء
يعني مباراه اليوم بين فرنسا والمغرب هي
بالتاكيد مباراه همم صعبه على كل الفريقين
لكن اي فريقين في رايك هو في تقديرك هو
الاوفر حظا للفوز المباراه والذي يمتلك
مقومات الفوز ايضا
صباح الخير يا احمد صباح الخير على كل
مشاهدين العربيه واحييكم على هذه التغطيه
المتميزه للاحداث الاغتيال ومباراه المغرب
بالتحديد مع فرنسا ولكن الحظوظ كره القدم
انا هنتمي الى ما قاله وليد الرجراجي في
المؤتمر الصحفي ان كره القدم تحتاج الى
تغيير في العقول او تغيير العقليه خاصه في
الدول الافريقيه بشكل عام فاذا كانت
الحظوظ كلها او التوقعات كلها تنتمي الى
فرنسا
فانا بانتمي النهارده الى هذا التغيير ان
المغرب امامه فرصه ان يفجر مفاجاه وان
يغير عقليته ووليد الرجراجي ويغير عقليته
ايضا ويفاجئ الفرنسيين بتكتي الجديد لان
التشابه هنا ليس في علاقات اللاعبين او
العلاقات المغربيه الفرنسيه لما التشابه
ايضا بين الشامبو وما بين وليد في الخطه
وفي التكتيك وفي الاستراتيجيه الاثنين
بيستخدموها الفرنسيين من 2018
همم تركوا ما يسمى بالاستحواذ لكل الفرق
واستطاعوا ان يفوزوا بكاس العالم بهذه
الطريقه الان ايضا طوال هذه المباريات
التي يلعبها الفرنسيين في كاس العالم 2022
يتركون الاستحواذ لكل الفرق واعتمدون على
التحركات السريعه
لثلاثي الهجوم وليد رجلي ايضا يستخدم هذه
الخطه ويستخدم هذا التكتيك في كل مباريات
وحتى مع البرتغاليين حتى مع الاسبان
الفرنسيين اليوم يخشون من فخر وليد
الركراكي في جاذبين الى ضربات الترجيح
فيحاولون كما فعلت الارجنتين امس مع
كرواتيا ان هم ينتهوا من المباراه في
الوقت الاصلي او على الاقل في الوقت
الاضافي ولا يذهبون الى ضربات الترجيح
للتالق ياسين بونو في تصدي فاليوم على
وليد الركراكي ان يغير تفكيره ان يفاجئ
الفرنسيين بتكتك الجديد ان يفاجئ فرنسيين
بضغط عالي وان يفاجئهم وهجوم يستطيع ان
يحرز هدفا لارباج كل حسابات جامب الذي
يعتمد عليها ان يترك الاحواز لوليد وان
يفاجاه
نعم الجمهور العربيه يراقب بشغف ايضا هذه
المباراه في مسانده عربيه غير مسروقه
للمنتخب العربي خاصه في كاس العالم في
تقديرك يعني هل سيشكل ذلك عامله ضغط ام
تحفيز المنتخب المغربي اليوم
هو هيبقى اثنين يعني يمكن دي شامبر بتكلم
على فكره ان المغرب همم لديه قاعده عريضه
جدا من الجمهور وتواجد الجمهور داخل
المدرجات وان ده في صالحه الجمهور يستطيع
ان يكون عامل مساعد للفريق عندما يساعد
الفريق ولا يضغط عليه ولا يطالبه
بالاهداف وانما يشجعه فقط يسانده فقط
ونظره احيانا المنتخب اعتقد ان رجليه عامل
حسابه على كده اللي هو تاهيل النفسي
والتاهيل والثبات النفسي بالنسبه للاعبين
كل هؤلاء اللاعبين محترفين اغلبهم محترفين
يتعاملون مع الجمهور بشكل اخر لكن التجهيز
النفسي في كاس العالم
الصغيره في المباراه يستطيع ان يكون
الجمهور ضغط على الفرنسيين اكثر شكرا
الرياضي طارق رمضان شكرا طارق
يشهد مونديال قطر 2022 حضور النسائيا
كبيرا حيث ارتفعت نسبه حضور النساء في
مدرجات الملاعب الى 65% التفاصيل مع زميل
ليث الزهري
لم تعد مباريات كره القدم حكرا على الذكور
ف مونديال قطر 2022 يشهد حضور النسائيا
كبيرا في مدرجات ملاعبه فقد رصد ارتفاعا
بنسبه 65% للجنس اللطيف من الفتيات
اللواتي اصبحنا يتابعنا المنتخبات
ولاعبيها فمنهم من تشارك في الهدافات
ومنهم من ترتدي الوان فريق بلدها او
المنتخب المفضل لديها
افضل كاس عالم احضره في حياتي الى جانب
الالعاب الاولمبيه وهو كاس مميز لانه يقام
في بلد رائع ومختلف
انا كسيده اشارك دائما في المونديال وكثير
من النساء في الارجنتين يقولون بذلك وهذا
امر طبيعي بالنسبه للانساء بلدي
صغير وكره القدم تشعرنا بالسعاده ولوكا
مودريتش سعداء اكثر من اي شيء
منتخبات المغرب والارجنتين والبرازيل لها
حصه الاسد من المشجعه فلن تتردد مشجعه تلك
المنتخبات بالظهور وهن يرتدين قمصان
منتخباتهم وسط الدوحه في سوق واقف ومنطقه
الشارب واللؤلؤه والكورنيش وحتى في محيط
الملاعب التي تقام على اراضيها المباريات
الختاميه للحصول على كاس عالم كره القدم
هذا العام الذي وحد العرب والعربيات حول
اللعبه الاكثر شعبيه في العالم
العربيه الدوحه دوله قطر
الاخبار الاقتصاد مع الزميله فاطمه الضاوي
فاطمه كيف حالك كيف شعورك وانت مغربيه
اليوم
انا مغربيه للقح اليوم يعني تركيزنا ان
شاء الله انه نفوز بهذا الماتش المهم مع
فرنسا ولازم يا احمد تحفظ الاغنيه الجديده
اللي احنا بنشجع بها المنتخب المغربي
[ضحك]
ايه ده دعونا الان على تداولات الاصوات
العالميه وايضا اسواق في المنطقه السوق
السعوديه يحلق عاليا يرتفع للجلسه الثانيه
على التوالي بيجيب حوالي 1.6 مئويه نقترب
من حاجز العشره الاف 1400 نقطه بينما باقي
الاسواق تتحرك في نطاق افقي ليس هناك كثير
من اخبار من الشركات التي يمكن ان تحرك
الاسواق ما عدا بالطبع مراقبتنا لتداولات
السهم الجديد امريكانا لمطاعم هذا السهم
المدرج بشكل ازواجي ما بين ابو ظبي والسوق
السعوديه الارتفاعات لا زالت مستمره عليه
وايضا قيمه دوله مرتفعه جدا على السهمين
لاحظوا امريكانا ثلاثه فاصله سته في المئه
من الارتفاعات في السعوديه وفي دباب ابو
ظبي بيضيف حواليه السته في المئه نراقب
ايضا سهما بالسعوديه السابق وايضا اسمنت
حيل على خلفيه توزيعاتها توصيه بتوزيع
ارباح نقديه سابك خفضوا نسبه التوزيعات
بحدود 25 هلا لا على مستوى النصف الثاني
هذه السنه لكن السهم ما زال يسجل ارتفاعات
ب 2.% توزيعات دائما بيكون شيء ايجابي
للتداولات على السهم واسمنت حايل ايضا
يرتفع بحدود الاثنين في المئه عالميا
الفوكس بالطبع على اجتماع الفيدرالي
المفروض نسمع نتائجه اليوم الساعه السابعه
توقيت جي ام سي السوق محتسب رفع ب 50 نقطه
اساس خصوصا بعد تباطؤ في ارقام التضخم
للولايات المتحده تشجعوا المغرب عوده اليك
احمد
شكرا لك فاطمه اذا مشاهدينا رفع باحثالي
اثيوبيان ومواظمه حقوقيه كينيا دعوه
قضائيه ضد شركه
تدعو الى العنف والكراهيه عبر منصاتها ما
ادى الى زياده حاله العنف والقتل وتاجيج
الصراع في اثيوبيا مطالبين الشركه باتخاد
خطوات طارئه للتصدي للمحتوى العنيف في ظل
فشل خوارزمياتها في تحديد المحتوى المحرض
عن العنف والكراهيه
[موسيقى]
الى عناوين
طيران تواصل معاقبه المحتجين بسجن المئات
وترجيحات بطرد ايران هيئه الامم المتحده
للمراه
انفجاراتنا عنيفه تهز العاصمه كيا ودفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه تسقط 13 مسيره
الايرانيه
وزير الدفاع الامريكي يحذر قاده افريقيا
من الدوري ليله تلعبه الصين وروسيا في
القاره السمراء
سيكون الاخير في مسيرته الكرويه بالبندق
نهايه هذه الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا شكل
حسن متابعه واكونوا بعافيه
[موسيقى]